nintendo vient d'annoncer la sortie
d'une prochaine console la news nintendo
de ds xl alors pourquoi pas c'est
toujours cool quand une nouvelle console
est annoncée d'autant plus que nintendo
généralement fait des consoles qui sont
top mais là messieurs un peu mitigé tu
vois je suis pas persuadé que le produit
soit génial je suis pas persuadé que le
nom de la console soit 1 et glisse-t-on
que c'est très confus alors il ya des
points positifs il ya des points
négatifs on va regarder ça ensemble on
va commencer par refaire un tour par
l'historique en commençant par la
nintendo ds parce que c'est une
évolution la nintendo ds alors tu es vu
la nintendo ds nintendo ds lite nintendo
ds et nintendo dsi xl nintendo 3ds
nintendo 3 ds xl nintendo ds in your
nintendo 3ds news nintendo 3 ds xl news
nintendo ds xl alors dans tout ça c'est
le bordel pour se repérer pour savoir
quelle console et quoi alors la ds bon
c'est la toute première elle remonte à
la 3ds c'est 2011 l'a2 dsc 2013 alors la
news nintendo 3 ds xl nintendo ds xl
c'est incompréhensible c'est le bordel
le plus complet autant que le concept de
la 3ds ou même de celle l'arrêt par un
concept qui est super sympa ta ta petite
console tu as tes jeux portatifs tâter
jeu portable tu peut les emmener partout
je préfère pas une chose c'est génial
mais le nom je suis qu'à moitié sur pas
sûr que ce soit une excellente idée ou
alors ils sont enfin un débriefing alors
de quoi va parler la console ben c'est
comme la 3ds mais y'a pas la 3d à ben
alors celle d'edf d'accord donc
mais il ya déjà une ds ah ouais ben
alors ça sera la nouvelle nintendo ds
ouais mais celle là alain grand écran ah
bah alors c'est la nouvelle nintendo dsi
xl nintendo ds xl aulas brainstorming
ont créé une marque comme ça paf c'est
parti pourquoi pas bon alors qu'est ce
qui est nouveau dans cette console parce
que cette console j'ai quand même des
particularités elle a quand même des
intérêts à savoir déjà que par rapport à
l'ancienne nintendo ds cette fois ci
elle a un écran qui à rabat à elle a un
double écran
l'écran du haut fait 4,88 pouces 400
rappard 240 ça c'est pour l'écran du
dessus l'écran du dessous par contre
fait 4,18 pousse donc rabattable 1 ça
change par rapport à 1 dans ce cas
nintendo ds c'est d'un seul bloc
il faut savoir que la première ligne m
dos de ds avait été fabriqué plus pour
un public jeune plus pour des enfants
c'était une petite ds incassable
normalement en tout cas qu'ils n'avaient
pas de points de fragilité comme
l'aspect avec le côté conte le rabat qui
peut effectivement un point un peu plus
sensibles on va retrouver un mini stick
analogique qui va être sensible à la
pression
donc on va pouvoir avoir en fonction des
jeux différentes possibilités en
fonction de la pression qu'on va exercer
sur le bouton des photons 30 qui seront
aussi supplémentaires par rapport à ce
qu'on avait sur l'ancien hôtel de
milliers d'électeurs puces sans fil pour
pouvoir interagir avec les animaux qui
sont messieurs ont vu sympa mais bon ça
tu le sais donc tu auras tes amis beau
et tu pourra les utiliser avec cette
nouvelle console c'est un écran standard
on dit standard parce qu'effectivement
il tenait pas d'afficher la 3d comme le
ferait une nintendo 3ds ou une nuit
de 3ds ou une huile d'ado 3 ds xl alors
par contre les super accepte console
c'est qu'elle est compatible avec
l'ensemble du catalogue 3ds de nintendo
la seule différence effectivement c'est
qu'il pourra pas profiter de la
fonctionnalité 3d est toujours à en 2d
mais ce qui est largement convenable
c'est une console qui valent disponible
dans deux couleurs tu auras îlots avec
turquoise et blanc et orange de la côte
est sont des joueurs qui sont très
sympas ces tendances montrent tout cas
je trouve plutôt bien choisi
l'un et l'autre sont des simples mix
retrouve pas quelque chose de trop girly
ou trop typé garçons voilà pour les
idéaux pour moi ça fonctionne bien peu
on indique en dehors des clichés pas
commenter ça ne c'est pas plus mal comme
je te le disais c'est la dixième console
ds dans la gamme ds et la 6e console à
partir de la 3ds
il ya eu 66 millions consoles écoulées à
partir de la nintendo 3ds est dans la
partie dsk lui 154 millions ce qui fait
un total de 220 millions de consoles
écoulées dans ses gammes df 3ds depuis
le début c'est monstrueux
nintendo annonce également un processeur
qui sera beaucoup plus rapide donc on
imagine des jeux sans temps de latence
un chargement rapide et un vrai confort
au niveau du gameplay une console qui
annonçaient un tout petit peu moins de
150 dollars sur le marché américain
j'ai regardé ça fait à peu près 137
euros par rapport au taux de change
actuel
ça reste une console qui est un tarif
vraiment accessible en si tu veux en
résumé pour moi si je me trompe aux
commentaires mais pour moi cette console
c'est comme la news nintendo 3ds
excellent
sauf que t'as pas la 3d auto
stéréoscopique d'eau stéréoscopique
c'est un peu dur à prononcer mais là
sauf que tu n'as pas la 3d auto
stéréoscopique
[Musique]
alors il ya quand même des points
positifs à retenir le tout premier set
catalogue de jeux comme je t'ai dit tu
peux utiliser l'ensemble des jeux de la
nintendo 3ds
ce qui fait qu'au final tâchez de cette
console elle innove mais elle a un
catalogue qui est monstrueux donc tu vas
pouvoir jouer à plein de jeux et ça
c'est génial autres pour un tract yves
ses prix 150 dollars c'est pas déconner
d'autant plus quand tu connais les jeux
derrière généralement on doit acheter
des jeunes notamment c'est ce qu'on
disait sur la nintendo switch à quelques
temps tu as acheté la console tu avais
quelques jeux annoncés mais tu sais pas
particulièrement ce qui allait arriver
après là par contre tu sais très
clairement à quels jeux pouvant jouer et
des nouveautés qui arrivent donc ça
c'est vraiment si super intéressant et
pour 150 dollars honnêtement ça va ça
déchire pas trop ça reste un tarif
accessible et puis l'autre point ça
reste quand même l'écran rabattables le
grand écran rabattables alors on est sur
un format 3d xl même si est une de ds xl
ça reste quand même un grand écran très
agréable à regarder
pour sabine pas les yeux on se fait
plaisir et ça c'est un super concept
weston
[Musique]
négatif maintenant ses consoles n'a pas
de 3d bah oui parce qu'en réalité elle a
tout de la news nintendo 3 ds xl mais
elle dès que news nintendo ds xl donc
pas de 3d ça c'est un point négatif
alors on le sent en achetant un produit
on n'achète pas l'hôpital de 31,6 elle
met une nintendo ds xl
ok ça on est au courant néanmoins voilà
donc ça c'est petit bémol
autre petit bémol la console n'a
toujours pas la possibilité de jouer à
plusieurs
pouvoir jouer avec une autre console à
côté de toi quelqu'un qui orne lamelle
qui aura une 3ds comme une donnée à 100
pour imaginer se connecter sur des
partis ensemble pourquoi pas sur des
jeux multijoueurs ça pourrait être sympa
bon ça ça n'existe pas je pense que
c'est aussi une reconnaissance en soit
une arme imparable pour moi ceci une
volonté de nintendo mais c'est pas grave
ça reste quand même une console avec
lequel il ya plein de jeux avec l on
peut lire s'amuser et dernier point
négatif c'est la date de sortie elle est
annoncée au 28 juillet en europe et aux
états unis
ces comptes [ __ ] c'est là que cette
console va profiter à tous les haïtiens
qui vont vouloir attaquer cette nouvelle
console tu penses à plaisir par contre
les juilletistes dans le cul lui c'est à
dire que tu pars en vacances en juillet
tu dis j'en ai ma console tiens je vais
chez celles là j'en ai pas de petites
consoles portatives ça pourrait être
sympa qu'on joué et battu peut pas ce
qui est dommage parce que tu vois qu'il
ya une date de sortie en australie qui
est au 15 juin
alors pourquoi l'australie par reste du
monde alors il a probablement une
question fabrication distribution comme
isation compagnie mais c'est con parce
que ça aurait pu être bien un être là au
début de l'été ça aurait permis
effectivement à tout le monde d'en
profiter et de s'éclater
voilà qui met ball alors que ma critique
par rapport à cette console c'est qu'on
a vraiment l'impression que sur ce que
si nintendo fait comme un peu les
fabricants de smartphones
même si j'aime beaucoup et technologies
je vais pas m'en plaindre mais j'ai
vraiment l'impression qu'ils font la
même chose ils sortent une console de ce
type là tous les ans afin de s'assurer
des ventes régulières mais sans réelle
innovation
parce que pass de la 3ds à la 2 ds
nintendo 3 ds xl à la new line tanoh de
ds xl
je vois pas trop l'intérêt d'autant plus
que de cataloguer même alors ça permet à
nintendo de toujours avoir une petite
innovation il n'y a pas réellement
d'innovation proposer une légère avancée
une une petite nouveauté à chaque fois
dans sa nouvelle console continue à
vendre des consoles continuer entre ces
jeux d'autant plus avec cette nouvelle
console ce qui est hyper intelligent
c'est de pouvoir continuer à vendre les
anciens jeux alors le march l'occasion
ils s'en foutent un peu mais par contre
sur neuf ça fonctionne toujours
ça permet d'entretenir la machine de
continuer à vendre ses titres devant de
ses licences pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
effectivement voit apple le fait pareil
à un tous les ans un smartphone qui sort
ça nous sommes c'est le même ils suivent
les rythmes il avance petite innovation
par petites innovations
il n'y a pas grande révolution ya
toujours un nouveau téléphone qui est là
et il ya toujours une vente ça permet
effectivement à l'entreprise de
continuer à avoir un certain chiffre
d'affaires d'être présent sur le marché
passé redoublé enfin toute une stratégie
qui s'est mise en place
et là c'est pareil pour nintendo c'est
dommage parce qu'on voit très bien
qu'avec la nintendo switch qui est sorti
a pas longtemps il ya une réelle avancée
il ya une réelle innovation et là il y
avait quelque chose et là avec la nounou
nintendo de ds xl il ya un grand chose
de neuf
c'est bien effectivement une bonne
console bonnes performances les
processeurs sont les technologies
actuelles on va qui vont un peu plus
vite
les écrans sont bien sont sympas enfin
les to qui sont convenables mais voilà
qu'il n'ya pas le petit déclic dès lors
c'est peut-être pour ça que nintendo n'a
pas sorti en grande pompe comme la
victoire sur la nintendo switch
peut-être pour ça qu'ils ont fini nonce
a un petit peu plus en catimini mais si
effectivement elle a peu reprise par
tout le monde
et voilà c'est un petit peu la critique
touche pourrait annoncer sur ce produit
sans un bon produit qui se tient si on
n'a jamais eu de console 3d est solide à
notre musique celle où rien dans cette
gamme là qu'on en a pas et qu'on veut y
aller je pense que c'est une bonne
console sur laquelle on peut se
positionner alors regardé par rapport à
la 3ds la 2d est effectivement le côté
3d intéressant ou pas pour toi si ça ne
l'est pas cette console est bien pour
150 dollars tu vas pas traîné si tu as
déjà une console nintendo 3ds excellent
une 3ds ou autres dans la gare donc
nécessairement grande utilité à changer
à mon sens sauf si effectivement tu as
la ds d'origine la ds high la ds lite
enfin lorsque tu veux un petit peu ce
coup là effectivement ça vaut tout de
suite gestion à mon avis voilà toi il
n'ya pas grand grand intérêt pour les
gens qui n'ont pas je te dis par contre
je pense passer une bonne console
pourquoi pas à regarder une petite
console à côté pour les vacances pour
les petits jeux alors une fois de plus
un les gens qui ont acheté la nintendo
switch on peut facilement prendre sa
façon des gens une console portative le
seul grand intérêt de cette console
c'est effectivement se dit de rentrer
dedans quand on en a pas c'est à dire
acheter une console de la gamme 3ds ds
si on n'a pas et surtout catalogue le
catalogue est là les jeux sont là ils
sont connus les titres phares et il ya
vraiment de quoi faire et ça c'est top
bon pour ma part je me devais d'en
parler parce que je couvrais aussi une
nouvelle console est toujours bien
effectivement présentes à qui peu sa
nouveauté mais j'aurais aussi bien pu de
parler de ce matin pour chiens et chats
coiffeur
[Musique]
gore par les choses bien plus
intéressantes comme le fait que j'ai
emmené liautaud parc pour essayer de
l'apprendre à faire du vélo ben ouais un
petit 3 ans qui arrive toujours pas
faire du vélo
bon il va y arriver mais faut les
encourager donc voilà
[Musique]
après commencé à 10 heures de classe
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
n'hésite pas à mettre un petit lac situé
à aimer abonne toi ma chaîne et on se
retrouve
il perd bientôt pour de nouvelles vidéos
ciao j'aime bien [ __ ] mes potes et ça
ça doit pas trop finale 20 6 ah ouais
d'accord n'a sûrement pas contre nous y
sommes et ça marche il a fait ça lui
même s'est pris pour un coiffeur de
sypris général qui n'est pas du tout
tendues je fais le port
[Musique]